okay let's address something that is
show related I want to get your feedback
about this for several years now is a
friday show the third segment of the
friday show is an old interview an
interview that's at least a couple of
years old that's relevant today in some
way shape or form very often with a new
introduction for me or some analysis
contextualizing the interview based on
what's going on today last week we tried
instead of doing one segment of live
calls and then going into a classic
interview skipping the classic interview
and doing two segments of live calls I
don't know that anybody noticed because
not a single person emailed me saying
hey David what happened to the classic
interview okay however we're doing that
again today so after the break we're
going to go to live calls and then we
will do a few more live calls instead of
a classic interview this is just a test
okay my question to you is do you prefer
to live call segments so we can get some
more live calls because we have a
whenever we take calls we've got 15 to
20 people holding we never get to all
the calls there's clearly pent-up demand
to use an economic term for more callers
do you prefer doubling up on live calls
and skipping the classic interview or
would you like to see the classic
interview return we've not made a
decision on this yet at least I haven't
made pat maybe made a decision and
didn't tell me but this is sort of an
open question right now I'd love to see
what the audience has to say because
when we asked what their favorite
segment of the show is a lot of people
said hey treat male yeah but I think
either first or second was live calls
indeed oh there's going to be a lot of
support for that and also people like
the interviews too and because they're
two three four years old a lot of the
new viewers have never had the chance to
sleep when you consider that the size of
our audience has doubled in the last
nine months a lot of people have never
seen or even heard of many of the
interviews that appear on a Friday
classic interview so let me know email
me david at david pakman.com let me know
your thoughts we can really go either
way and what would also I wonder how
this will be a factor which is that some
people hate live calls although
interviews and live calls are two of the
most liked as aspects of the show
interviews and live calls or two of the
most disliked aspects of the show by
other people some people skip the
interview
all together so for them doubling up on
live calls is great they were skipping
the interviews anyway other people
prefer the interviews that's their
favorite part of the show and they may
now be upset that we've gone from five
interviews a week down to only for
monday through thursday so i really
don't know where people are going to
come away with this but the lesson here
Pat is email me david at david
pakman.com and tell me which you prefer
I mean it certainly seems to be one of
these polarizing issues it's not one of
those things that everyone can agree on
like that we should have less sports on
the show for example yes indeed that
seemed to be that seemed to be almost
unanimous among the audience that there
should be no discussion of sports on the
show I hate to break it to you every
once in a while there's going to be
discussions of sports especially with
World Cup 2018 coming up which number
one the location completely immoral and
indicative of corruption and broader
issues which i will be talking about and
argentinian men's national team which
how could we not talk about that and the
jersey ik i warned you pat will be
coming back out next year and the
coverage of the pickup basketball game
that i've played with my friends over
the past few weeks oh yeah ball that i
mean that's that's going to be the lead
story on monday make a note of that
alright let's take a break i'm on
twitter at d pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show